This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个iHeart播客。百分之二。那是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《百分之二》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养精神坚韧度、体能以及复原力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《百分之二》。节目名称是两个字：“百分之二”。在《回溯往事》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和我这一代人来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一期节目，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔畅谈80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《回溯往事》。嘿，各位，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖恩斯主持的《知难而进》。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方都绝对不安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个懂行的执照专业人士一起探讨。有多少男人穿着一套精神铠甲。它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。而且，仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你非得这么做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在AHA广播应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《知难而进》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的检测报告两次，对吗？我伪造了一次检测报告。互联网侦探们出动了大批人马，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。还有两个男人也经历过同样的事情。格雷格，一个女同性恋者。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑彻底炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这里是《深陷爱河》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于自食恶果。在iHeart广播应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，在这个播客里，我们探讨二十岁时经历的一些重大生活改变和过渡，以及它们对我们的意义。
for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of our 20s. Let's talk about something that has been really bugging me recently.
对我们的心理学意味着什么。大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到播客，新听众、老听众，无论你们身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你们能来到这里，收听又一期节目，当然，我们在此剖析二十岁的心理学。让我们来聊聊最近一直让我感到非常苦恼的一件事。
I'm not having fun. I am not having as much fun as I think I should be having. And it is really getting me into a rut. I'm not having fun. Simple as that. And I feel like in this decade, I'm still in my 20s. It's upsetting me. It's frustrating me that this should be my time to be embracing experiences.
我一点都不开心。我没有获得我本该拥有的那种快乐。这真的让我陷入了一种陈规俗套。我一点都不开心。事情就是这么简单。我觉得在这个十年里，我还正当二十岁。这让我心烦意乱。这让我感到沮丧，因为这本该是我拥抱各种体验的黄金时期。
And it's just not happening. Tell me if you relate to this. I feel as if my entire life at this stage is dominated by my to-do list or my should-do list. And it is lingering over me constantly. even when things are done, there is always more to add on to the list. Unhealthy, yes, impossible to escape. That's what I've been finding. This toxic focus on productivity has made just having fun for the simple act of it.
可它偏偏没有发生。告诉我，你是否有同感。我觉得在这个阶段，我的整个生活都被我的“待办事项清单”或“应该做的事清单”主导着。它一直萦绕在我心头，挥之不去。即使事情做完了，清单上也总会有新的任务加进来。不健康，是的；无法逃避，这也是我所发现的。这种对高效率的病态关注，让仅仅为了单纯的好玩而去玩这件事情。
Kind of feel like a chore, but more so like something that needs to be dismissed for as long as possible, because God forbid I'm not working hard enough. or I don't prove myself or I look back at this time and can trace future failures back to this one afternoon that I took off. This one day I said, I'm just going to go to the beach instead. What if my decision then changes my life for the worse? What if prioritizing fun in that moment means to satisfaction long term? It's a pretty toxic mindset to be in.
感觉有点像做家务，甚至更像是一件应该尽可能长时间地推迟的事，因为天知道要是我的工作不够努力，或者我没有证明自己，或者我回顾这段时间时，发现未来的失败竟然要归咎于我请假的这个下午。归咎于我说的“今天我偏要直接去海滩”的这一天。万一我当时的决定把我的生活变得更糟呢？万一那一刻把快乐放在首位意味着长期的不满足呢？这是一种相当病态的心态。
I acknowledge that. But the other element of this for me is that life, I think the world in general feels so serious and terrible at this time and you know I had someone say to me the other day it feels like we're living in end times and I honestly relate to that feeling so having fun sometimes makes me feel guilty it's also harder to be present in fun moments at this stage because you're constantly being pulled back down to earth and back into reality by all the terrible things you see in the news or that come across your feed and so I asked you all the listeners this very question I've asking myself, are you having fun? Are you enjoying your life right now? Only 27% of you said yes.
我承认这一点。但对我来说，这件事的另一个层面是，我觉得生活，我觉得整个世界在此时此刻都显得如此凝重和糟糕，你知道，前几天有人对我说，感觉我们正生活在末世，老实说，我真的能体会到那种感觉。因此，有时候找乐子会让我产生负罪感。在这个阶段，要全神贯注于欢乐的时刻也变得更加难得，因为你不断被新闻中看到的或信息流里刷到的所有可怕的事情拉回地面，拉回现实。所以我问了你们所有听众这个问题，这也是我一直在问自己的问题：你开心吗？你现在在享受生活吗？只有百分之二十七的回答是“是的”。
When I asked how often you have fun, only 18% of you said every day. And 63% of you said, you wish your life was more fun. This final question I asked was, do you think we take our 20s too seriously? And 76% of you said yes. Yes. Yes. We do. And so I had to ask myself, is that the culprit behind why we, I am not having fun right now? And I think it goes even deeper than that. We're going to touch on some of those explanations, but recently I have been reading this book titled The Fun Habit by the psychologist Mike Rucker. And he has this quote in his book that really, really stood out for me and which inspired this episode. happiness is a state of mind but fun is something you have to do not just think about it also doesn't
当我问你们多久玩乐一次时，只有百分之十八的人回答“每天”。百分之六十三的人说，他们希望自己的生活能更有趣。我问的最后一个问题是，你觉得我们把二十岁过得太严肃了吗？百分之七十六的人回答“是的”。是的。是的。我们的确如此。所以我不禁要问自己，这就是为什么我们——或者说我——现在一点都不快乐的罪魁祸首吗？我想这背后的原因还要更深。我们将探讨其中的一些解释，但最近我一直在读心理学家迈克·鲁克尔（Mike Rucker）撰写的一本名为《快乐习惯》（The Fun Habit）的书。他在书中有这样一句话，真的深深触动了我，也正因如此，才有了这期节目：幸福是一种心态，但快乐是你必须去付诸行动的事情，而不仅仅是去想想。它也不
require education money or power all it requires is intentionality and that just i don't know what it was you know when you hear certain things and they just change something in your mind that was one of those quotes and so as of a week ago i'm on a mission to make my life more fun and i want to bring you along with me. Turns out as well, there are not just mental health benefits to this, but it may just be something. Having more fun could be something that extends your life. It keeps you healthier. And really at the end of the day, I mean, you are living your life for you. That is everything that this life should mean. You are living your life to have unique, enjoyable experiences. And I think that is something that we need to be deliberately reminded of every now and again,
需要学历、金钱或权力。它唯一需要的，就是意图。而那一刻，我不知道是什么感觉，你知道那种当你听到某些话，它们瞬间改变了你脑海中的某些东西的感觉吗？这就是其中金句之一。所以从一周前开始，我踏上了一项让我的生活变得更有趣的使命，我想带你们一起同行。事实证明，这不仅有益于心理健康，还可能带来别的好处。寻找更多快乐可能会成为一种延年益寿的方式。它能让你更健康。说到底，其实，你是在为自己而活。这就是生活本该意味着的一切。你活着是为了获得独特、愉悦的体验。我认为这是我们需要时常被刻意提醒的一点，
especially when there are a lot of reasons made up or real to not be prioritizing enjoyment and delight. So today we are going to look at the psychology behind fun, how to find fun in unexpected ways, including in hard work and some of the best yet, also less obvious ways for creating delight, creating playfulness, creating joy. I think it's something we could all do with a little bit more of, myself included, I'm in this boat with you. And the science also says the same. So without further ado, let's get into our tips, the psychology behind how you can just have more fun in your life. Let's start with my argument for why we should be more focused on fun, not just in your 20s, but in every stage of your life. I think so many of us
尤其是在有成百上千个冠冕堂皇或现实的理由不去把享受和快乐放在首位的时候。所以今天我们将探讨快乐背后的心理学，如何在意想不到的方式中寻找乐趣，包括在努力工作中寻找，以及创造愉悦、创造趣味、创造喜悦的最佳却又最显而易见的方法。我认为我们所有人都可以多体验一点这些，包括我自己，我和你们在同一条船上。科学研究也同样证实了这一点。废话少说，让我们进入我们的技巧环节，探讨如何让你的生活获得更多快乐的心理学。让我们从我为什么认为我们应该更加关注快乐的论点开始，不仅是在二十岁，而是在你人生的每一个阶段。我想我们当中有太多人
are focused on happiness, not realizing that happiness is one of the hardest emotional. to create through external means. We desperately chase this very elusive feeling, but what researchers will tell you is that it's quite difficult to obtain. We need to find a gateway to it. And fun is one of those gateways to happiness through joy. Fun is like a shortcut. It's like an instantaneous jump the cue card.
专注于追求幸福，却没意识到幸福是最难通过外在手段创造的情感之一。我们拼命追逐这种极其虚幻的感觉，但研究人员会告诉你，它相当难以捉摸。我们需要找到通往它的门户。而快乐就是通往幸福的其中一个门户，通过喜悦。快乐就像一条捷径。它就像一张瞬间跳过排队卡片的特权。
Like if you can have fun, you can obtain happiness a lot easier. I think fun is something that is depicted as A, very childish and be very frivolous. There is a time and a place for it, mainly in childhood, but at some stage you need to outgrow that. The older you get, the more you need to be mature, the less time there is for that. There's no need for it. That's what people are kind of assuming. But when we get existential about it, which we often do in this podcast, what does life really mean unless it is filled with experiences that leave an impact and that you can enjoy?
就像如果你能感受到快乐，你就能更容易地获得幸福。我认为快乐往往被描绘成：A，非常幼稚；B，非常轻浮。它有其对应的时间和场合，主要在童年时期，但在某个阶段你需要超越它。你年纪越大，你就越需要成熟，留给那种快乐的时间就越少。根本没有那个必要。这正是人们普遍的假设。但当我们开始对此进行存在主义的思考时——我们在播客中经常这样做，如果生活不充满能留下深刻印记且能让你享受其中的体验，
joy that you can reminisce on that fill you with this unnameable bright, gooey feeling. Maybe that's what piece is. You may not be able to have fun all the time, but you are also not a machine. And as the saying goes, an unexamined life is a life not worth living. And I think a fun life is a life not worth living either. I'm going to throw some psychological research at you as well if you need more convincing that fun is important. Fun also on a practical level fosters what is known as psychological flexibility,
充满那种能让你回味无穷、让你内心充满那种无法言喻的明亮、黏糊糊的感觉的喜悦，那么生活究竟意味着什么？也许那就是平静。你可能无法时时刻刻都尽情玩乐，但你也绝不是一台机器。正如那句名言所说：“未经审视的人生不值得过。”而我认为，没有乐趣的人生同样不值得过。如果你需要更多的说服来相信快乐的重要性，我将向你抛出一些心理学研究。从实用层面来看，快乐还能促进所谓的心理灵活性，
and that is our ability to adapt to life's demands with openness and curiosity rather than rigidity. So it's the distinction between a fixed mindset versus a growth mindset. So if you are having fun, you're also going to be more flexible, more adaptable, you're going to be a better problem solver, you're going to be less pessimistic. Fun also deeply strengthens social bonds between others, which we're going to explore in a second. And having more fun and playfulness and joy in your life has been proven to lower cortisol levels and increase neuroplasticity in the brain. Neuroplasticity is one of the most essential concepts that you need to understand if you want to achieve, do create, be anything.
这就是我们以开放和好奇而非僵化的态度去适应生活需求的能力。所以，这是固定型思维模式与成长型思维模式之间的区别。因此，如果你在享受快乐，你也会变得更加灵活、更具适应力，你会成为一个更好的问题解决者，也会变得不那么悲观。快乐还能深深地加强人与人之间的社会纽带，我们稍后将对此进行探讨。并且，事实证明，在生活中增加快乐、趣味和喜悦可以降低皮质醇水平，并增强大脑的神经可塑性。神经可塑性是你想要成就、创造、成为任何事情时都必须理解的最基本的概念之一。
It is the explanation. it is the single thing that is responsible for you being able to change who you are, grow, learn, and adapt throughout your lifetime. So if you want to achieve anything in life, whatever it is for you, you have to tune into the ways that you are going to allow your brain to be plastic and to be moldable. And it turns out fun is one of those things. Fun can also come in various packaging, I guess.
它是唯一的解释。它是让你能够在一生中改变自我、成长、学习和适应的决定性因素。因此，如果你想在生活中取得任何成就，无论那对你意味着什么，你都必须调动自己，去寻找那些能让你的大脑保持可塑性和可塑性的方法。事实证明，快乐就是其中之一。快乐也可以有各种不同的包装，我想。
There is this idea of type 1 and type 2 fun. that I came across recently, and it's a concept that was created by very serious outdoor enthusiasts who realized that their idea of fun was very different to the average person. You know, they didn't find much pleasure in going to the movies, but they could run 100 miles and feel ecstasy and enjoyment like nothing else. They could cycle until their knees gave out, jump off cliffs, do extreme things. That was where fun lay for them. So what was the created was this distinction between type 1 and type 2 fun type 1 fun it's very typical it's enjoyable when it's happening going to the beach classic type 1 fun hanging out with your friends card games
最近我偶然接触到一个概念，叫做“第一类快乐”和“第二类快乐”，这是一个由非常严肃的户外运动爱好者创造的概念，他们意识到他们对快乐的理解与普通人截然不同。你知道，他们觉得去看电影并没有什么乐趣，但他们可以跑上一百英里，感受到无与伦比的狂喜和享受。他们可以骑自行车直到双膝发软，从悬崖上跳下，做一些极限运动。那才是他们乐趣所在的地方。于是，他们创造了第一类快乐和第二类快乐之间的区别。第一类快乐非常典型，它在发生时就令人愉快，比如去海滩就是典型的第一类快乐，和朋友闲逛，玩纸牌游戏，
roller coasters fun you can opt into them and the fun surrounds you type 2 fun you have to work for it's very different it is the kind of fun that only comes after you have completed the activity not during it. It is the feeling of doing something difficult and almost hating it, like feeling uncomfortable, but having this predominant feeling of adventure and accomplishment and enjoyment. Now, you're probably thinking, what, that's just relief, right? That's the relief at finishing something. Not necessarily, you know, you're not going to finish a major assignment or a large work project and be like, that was fun. We're going to be like, thank gosh, that's over. type 2 fun is specifically to do with things that are still leisure and that are not required of you,
坐过山车，这些是你可以自主选择参与的快乐，快乐环绕着你。至于第二类快乐，你必须为之付出努力，它非常不同。它是那种只有在活动结束之后才会产生的快乐，而不是在活动进行时。它是做一件困难的事，甚至几乎讨厌它时的感觉，就像感到不舒服，但同时内心有一种强烈的冒险、成就感和享受。现在你可能会想，什么，那不就是解脱吗？那是完成某事后的释怀。不一定，你知道的，你不会在完成一项重大作业或一个大型工作项目后说：“这真好玩。”你会说：“谢天谢地，总算结束了。”第二类快乐专门与那些依然属于休闲、并不强求你去做的事情有关，
but that you opt into and that you work towards. What you're experiencing when you experience type 2 fun is called harmonious passion. It is being absorbed in an activity that you choose to do because you love it and you love how it makes you feel, even when it's not making you happy at the time. So there's also this final category of fun called type three fun. This is the kind of fun. It's not fun in the moment. It's not fun in retrospect, but it makes a good story.
但却是你主动选择并为之努力的事情。当你体验到第二类快乐时，这种体验被称为“和谐激情”。这就是全身心投入到你选择的一项活动中，因为你热爱它，你热爱它带给你的感觉，即使它在当时并没有让你感到快乐。所以，还有最后一种被称为第三类快乐的类别。这就是那种类型的快乐。它在当下并不好玩。事后回想起来也不好玩，但它能构成一个很好的故事。
It's a story or an experience that bonds to people together. So being chased by a bear on a hike. That's type three fun. Type three fun we're kind of going to ignore here. The argument that is typically made is that it's very easy to just have type one fun these days. Anything that gets our dopamine going that connects us is type one. fun. We need to be having more type 2 fun. We cannot just reserve hard work for things that don't bring us joy or that aren't things we want to do. We have to use hard work for things that will
这是一个能将两个人紧密联系在一起的故事或经历。比如在徒步旅行时被一头熊追赶。这就是第三类快乐。第三类快乐我们在这里就不多讨论了。通常人们提出的论点是，如今要获得第一类快乐实在是太容易了。任何能刺激我们多巴胺分泌、将我们连接在一起的事物都是第一类快乐。我们需要体验更多第二类快乐。我们不能把辛苦工作仅仅留给那些不能给我们带来快乐或并非我们想做的事情。我们必须把努力工作用在那些能以一种极好的、休闲的、自我导向的方式来
challenge and excite us in a fantastic, leisurely, self-directed way. The thing is, we know that fun is doing good things for our brains and for our bodies and for our social connections, but it's not necessarily something that we can prescribe. Like, your doctor isn't. You know, going to prescribe you an amusement park. They're not going to give you a pill full of fun. I find the statement like, are you having fun? So interesting. It's like, are you having dinner? Are you having a glass of wine? Are you having this thing we call fun? Like it's something that we can serve up or that we can buy or we can consume or create a dosage of. What we really need to be focused on is everyday behaviors and ways that fun is reinforced in our minds as a priority. So let's talk about that.
挑战和兴奋我们的事情上。问题是，我们知道快乐对我们的大脑、身体和社交关系都有好处，但它并不是我们能够通过处方开出来的那种东西。就像你的医生不会。你知道的，给你开一张游乐园的门票。他们不会给你一颗充满快乐的药丸。我发现“你开心吗？”这句话非常有趣。这就好像在问：你在吃晚饭吗？你在喝一杯葡萄酒吗？你在体验我们称之为“快乐”的东西吗？就好像这是一种我们可以端上桌、可以购买、可以消费或可以按剂量的东西。我们真正需要关注的是日常行为，以及在我们的心中将快乐巩固为优先事项的方式。所以，让我们来谈谈这个。
Let's talk about the six ways you can integrate fun as a daily practice. The same way you shower, the same way you make breakfast, the same way you exercise. The first way that we can be having more fun is to put fun on the calendar and to be deliberate about it. The reason I found I couldn't allow myself time to have fun is that. not because I didn't have the time or I didn't have the space, it's because I didn't make the space. I didn't make the time. Your life is truly made of the things that you prioritize. That's a choice that you get to make. And I'm going to ask you, a very serious question, how much time do you prioritize spending on your phone each day? How much time do you spend staying late at the office
让我们来谈谈将快乐作为日常习惯融入生活的六种方法。就像你洗 澡一样，就像你做早餐一样，就像你锻炼身体一样。我们能获得的更多快乐的第一种方法，是将快乐排进日程表，并为此采取深思熟虑的行动。我发现自己无法留出时间来享受快乐，原因不是。因为我没有时间或没有空间，而是因为我没有腾出空间。我没有腾出时间。你的生活真正由你所优先对待的事物组成。那是你可以做出的选择。我要问你一个非常严肃的问题：你每天花多少时间刷手机？你在办公室呆到多晚？
or the library when you don't actually have anything to do. How much time do you spend doing things for other people that probably won't appreciate it? Not being intentional accidentally ends up causing us to prioritize things we don't actually see as important or that we shouldn't see as important. So this is the challenge. Once a week, I want you to take an afternoon, even an evening or a whole day off on the weekends to schedule in fun the same way you would schedule in. a check-in with your boss.
或者在图书馆里，而你实际上根本没什么事可做。你花多少时间为那些可能并不感激你的人做事？缺乏意图最终会无意中导致我们优先去关注那些我们实际上并不认为重要、或者根本不该认为重要的事情。所以这就是挑战。每周一次，我想让你抽出一个下午，甚至是一个晚上，或者周末整整一天的时间，把快乐像安排与老板开会一样
Perhaps you can even adapt this to be once a month, whatever works for you. Once a month, you take yourself out of town for a fun day. You do an activity. The way I've integrated this, but there's a couple ways, but the first is that I've made a bucket list of sorts of all the things that I want to do in Sydney,
排入日程表。也许你甚至可以将其调整为每月一次，总之什么对你有效就行。每月一次，你把自己带出城去度过快乐的一天。你进行一项活动。我融入这一点的方式有几种，但首先是我列了一个愿望清单，记录了所有我想在悉尼做的事情，
in the city that I live, that I am working to tick off. And I say work, because that's sometimes what it feels like at the beginning. It's always going to feel like work when you are changing your routine. but it takes on average three months for something to become a habit. Three months, according to the European Journal of Social Psychology.
在我居住的这座城市，我正在努力去把它们一项项勾掉。我之所以说“努力”，是因为一开始感觉确实像是在工作。当你改变日常生活习惯时，它总是会感觉像是在工作。但据《欧洲社会心理学杂志》报道，某种行为平均需要三个月才能成为习惯。三个月。
So if you make fun at practice, that's literally only 12 weeks before it is an inbuilt part of your life. Here's another way that I am integrating this. It's called the Sunday Dilly Dally. And I'm almost at two months of doing the Dilly Dally. So I've got one more month before hopefully it's a habit, but this is how it works. Me and my friends, we have our Run Club. in the mornings on Sundays.
所以如果你把快乐变成一种实践，仅仅十二周之后，它就会成为你生活中内置的一部分。这是我融入这一点的另一种方式。它被称为“周日闲逛”（Sunday Dilly Dally）。我进行这种“闲逛”快两个月了。所以再有一个月，它差不多就能成为一个习惯了，具体机制是这样的。我和我的朋友们成立了我们的跑步俱乐部。
We call it anti-social, social run club. We meet at 8.30 at the park. We don't even run together. Like, we do not even run. Together, we have our headphones in the entire time. But we meet back at the same spot after about an hour. And then we all go and we do chores together. And we have no agenda, no plan, no timeline.
在周日的早晨。我们称之为“反社交的社交跑步俱乐部”。我们在8:30在公园碰面。我们甚至不一起跑步。真的，我们甚至不跑步。在一起跑步的时候，我们全程都塞着耳机。但在大约一个小时后，我们在同一个地点集合。然后我们一起去处理杂务。我们没有议程，没有计划，没有时间表。
The only objective is to dilly-dally. If you want to go and try all the samples at the deli, okay we don't yeah let's do it you want to buy new shoes that's fine you want to randomly get your ears pierced you want to get your hair cut great and you know my friends are all these really impressive people their social workers their department heads their lawyers and what we always say at the end of this is like isn't it just so nice for one day of our weeks to not be structured to allow us to have fun in an organic way before this i think it even felt like sometimes My Saturdays and Sundays were like becoming work days for me because I would still be working,
唯一的目的就是闲逛。如果你想去熟食店尝试所有的试吃样品，好吧，我们不——是的，让我们去吧。你想买新鞋？那也行。你想随机去打个耳洞吗？你想去剪个头发吗？太棒了。你知道我的朋友们都是些非常了不起的人，他们是社工、部门主管、律师，而我们在活动结束时总是会说：“一周里能有一天不用按部就班，能以一种自然的方式享受快乐，难道不是太美妙了吗？”在此之前，我觉得有时我的周六和周日就像成了我的工作日，因为一方面我还在工作，
first of all, but I would also be scheduling in people. And I felt pressure to be the most productive I could be with my free time, which is ridiculous and such an oxymoron. But the dilly dally has been the solution for me. So schedule and your fun. If you don't make something a conscious priority, it will slip through the cracks, especially when there are objectively millions of other things that you could do. with that time. The thing to ask yourself is, why do I see those other things that are often chores or requirements of me is more important than my enjoyment. The Dilly Daily example actually brings me to tip number two and it was inspired by a study titled, Fun is more fun when others are
而且我还会把各种人约进日程里。我感到有压力，必须把我的空闲时间利用得最高效，这真是荒谬至极，简直是个莫大的讽刺。但“闲逛”对我和我的朋友们来说就是解决方案。所以，把你的快乐排入日程表。如果你不把某件事作为有意识的优先事项，它就会从裂缝中溜走，尤其是当客观上有成百上千件其他事情你可以用那些时间去做的时候。你要问自己的问题是：为什么我把那些通常是家务或对我的要求的事情，看得比我的享受更重要？“闲逛”这个例子实际上让我想到了第二个技巧，它的灵感来自于一项名为《当有他人参与时，快乐会更有趣》的研究。
involved. You need to invite people into your deliberate, delightful moments and it will make them better. So the study I was talking about, it was conducted in 2016 and the researchers recruited 119 individuals, some of them in New York, Arizona, across the United States, and they would essentially call these individuals multiple times a day and ask them, hey, like, what are you up to? Are you enjoying yourself? Are you alone? Are you having fun? Are you with others? They then also included a bunch of other psychometrics and measures for low arousal and positive affect. So basically, they wanted to know, was someone calm, was someone relaxed? Were they content, at ease, or were they stressed. And what they found, these results were so clear, fun, experienced with other people,
你需要邀请人们加入你那些深思熟虑的、令人愉悦的时刻，这会让它们变得更好。我刚才提到的那项研究是在2016年进行的，研究人员招募了119名个人，其中一些在纽约、亚利桑那州，遍布全美。他们基本上会一天多次打电话给这些人，问他们：“嘿，你在干嘛呢？你现在过得开心吗？你是一个人吗？你开心吗？你和别人在一起吗？”他们随后还纳入了一堆其他的心理测量指标以及用于低唤醒度和积极情感的测量方法。基本上，他们想知道的是，某人是否平静，某人是否放松。他们是满足的、自在的，还是感到压力的。他们发现，这些结果非常明确：与他人一起体验的快乐，
is more positive and more enjoyable than solitary fun. Actually, they even want a step further and said that just having other people around us, specifically friends, automatically activates a pre-fun mindset and state. Now, the highest form of fun amongst friends, it's actually learning something new together or engaging in an activity. This could also be known as parallel play. I love the term parallel play. It's something that was borrowed from developmental psychology and it basically refers to two people being together in the same room, doing things side by side without necessarily doing the same thing. They're just enjoying each other's presence and conversation and that for us is fun. It really activates some very primal human instinct for community.
比独自一人的快乐更加积极、更加令人愉快。事实上，他们甚至更进一步指出，仅仅是身边有其他人（特别是朋友）陪伴，就能自动激活一种“预快乐”的心态和状态。现在，朋友之间最高形式的快乐，其实是一起学习新事物或参与一项活动。这也可以被称为“平行游戏”。我非常喜欢“平行游戏”这个词。它是从发展心理学中借用过来的概念，基本上指的是两个人待在同一个房间里，并肩做各自的事情，而不一定要做完全相同的事情。他们只是在享受彼此的陪伴和交谈，对我们而言，这本身就是快乐。它真正激活了某种非常原始的人类对社群的本能。
And this idea that enjoyment needs to be shared, fun needs to be shared. I think parallel play also removes the pressure to be on all the time and to fill the space with just talking or to constantly maintain emotional openness and focus. You know what, this time in my life, sometimes I'm just too exhausted to just sit with someone for three hours and talk and have dinner. Fun is like the easy way to still really enjoy someone's presence, but to be doing things independently that you equally enjoy. There is this amazing article from the New York Times.
以及这种“快乐需要分享，趣味需要分享”的想法。我认为平行游戏还消除了必须时刻保持营业状态、必须用源源不断的对话填满空间，或者必须时刻保持情感开放和专注的压力。你知道吗，在我人生现阶段的某些时候，我有时实在太累了，无法只是和某人坐上三个小时聊天吃晚饭。而快乐就像是一种轻松的方式，既能真正享受某人的陪伴，又能各自独立地做着你们同样喜欢的事情。《纽约时报》上曾刊登过一篇精彩绝伦的文章。
It's titled, Let's Ignore Each Other in the Same Room. And it basically articulates how much this kind of practice and these kinds of activities are really essential for us, especially in this day and age, when it is a lot easier to interact and maintain social body. online. Parallel play might just be the solution. Okay, we're going to take a short break, but when we return, let's discuss my final three tips, including some contributions from you guys, the listeners on how to make life more fun. A few of these suggestions were genuinely hilarious and also genius, so stay tuned after this short break.
它的标题是《让我们在同一个房间里互相忽略吧》。它基本上阐明了这种实践和这类活动对我们是多么至关重要，尤其是在当今这个时代，在网上进行互动和维持社交纽带要容易得多。平行游戏可能正是解决方案。好了，我们要稍作休息，但等我们回来后，让我们讨论我最后的三个技巧，包括你们这些听众对如何让生活更有趣的一些贡献。其中一些建议真的非常搞笑，同时也极具天才般的创意，所以请在短暂的休息后继续收听。
2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalation. available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO
百分之二。那是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《百分之二》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养精神坚韧度、体能以及复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾深信植物油本质上具有炎症性。我们大错特错了。我们在世界上遇到的许多问题，都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《百分之二》。节目名称是两个字：“百分之二”。
percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And Rule 2, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist.
每个男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。规则一，绝不要惹乡下姑娘。玩愚蠢的游戏，你就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也绝不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《女朋友们》的这个新季节里……我的天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过。
I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends.
我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在乎。所以她们决定自己采取行动。我说：“哦，见鬼，绝不。”我发誓我将成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到应有的下场。收听《女朋友们》。
Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim?
相信我，宝贝。在iHeart广播应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金姆的胸部吗？或者坎耶说乔治·布什不关心黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金姆到底有什么关系？
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the AIDS. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack.
好吧，你可以在《回溯往事》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一期节目，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。其中包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）合作的节目，畅谈可卡因与艾滋病。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅因为可卡因。我随时准备聊聊当时的可卡因，只是为了让你们知道。我是说，马克，到了这个时候，这已经是我们探讨可卡因的第二期节目了。
So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history.
所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的主线。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在桌面上。谢谢你把话说完。是的。我认为没有哪个年份对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan, Ryan, Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch.
请在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《回溯往事》。欢迎收听我的新播客《知难而进》，我是你们的主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师科尔·盖恩斯。为了致敬心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与众多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是，特里普·方丹、瑞恩、瑞恩，有时当我们执着于追求某样东西时，我们会如此深陷于追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们却仍在追逐。我们甚至不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总在盯着计分板。
Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way.
生活变成了一场关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你们觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要。你成为一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。这也是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地做一个好人。加入我，科尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《知难而进》中，让我们就治愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。
Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. Having fun and being silly seem to go hand in hand. Sometimes they're seen as synonymous. And this really brings me to my third tip for making everyday life more fun. Turn mundane things into a game. pair a thing you hate doing with something that is like just short of feeling stupid, but so enjoyable. So this kind of strategy, it's actually called lifestyle gamification, and it was a method that I
打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用。搜索“Learn the Hardway”并立即收听。玩乐和傻气似乎密不可分。有时它们被视为同义词。这真的让我想到了让日常生活更有趣的第三个技巧。把平凡的事情变成一场游戏。将一件你讨厌做的事情与一件听起来有点像在装傻但却无比愉快的事情搭配起来。这种策略实际上被称为“生活游戏化”，我相信这最初是一种作为帮助视频游戏成瘾者的方法而出现的。这些人对视频游戏呈现的虚拟环境上瘾，在那里事情会得到奖励，你可以获胜，一切都不是那么严肃，既神奇又美妙，人们显然会沉迷其中。为了让他们摆脱这种状态，这些研究人员基本上想的是：如果我们把日常生活变成一场游戏会怎么样？你可以为自己这样做。想想一个你讨厌的家务。世界上你最讨厌做的事情，你该如何将其游戏化，让它变得更有趣？我举个例子。我有一个可怕的习惯，就是早上把家里弄得一团糟。承认这一点让我觉得自己在成长，因为这就像我的小秘密，但我从来不
believe was first emerging as a way to help people with video game addictions. So these individuals were becoming addicted to the artificial environments presented by video games, where things were rewarded, and it was you could win and nothing was too serious and it was magical and amazing and people would obviously become engrossed in that. And to get them out of that, these researchers were basically like, what if we turn everyday life into a game? You could do this for yourself. Think about a chore you hate. The thing you hate most in the world having to do, how can you gamify this so that it's more enjoyable. And I'll give you an example. I have this terrible habit of making an absolute disgrace of my house in the mornings. I feel like growth admitting it because it's like my little secret, but I never
把东西放回它们该去的地方。我只是把东西到处乱扔。但我又极其讨厌上床睡觉时家里不整洁。你知道的，如果地上有衣服，如果东西摆得乱七八糟，我就睡不好觉。我脑海里有两个不同的人在分别掌管。早晨和晚上的事务。巨大的矛盾，但我姐姐教了我这个技巧，她称之为“拯救世界十分钟”，她设置一个十分钟的定时器，在定时器响铃之前，她有十分钟的时间尽可能多地打扫卫生，或者她会做五分钟，看看能不能洗完所有的盘子，这就像是一场赛跑。
put things back where they belong. I just like throw things everywhere. But I also despise not having a tidy house when I go to bed. You know, if there are clothes on the floor, if things are not in order, I'm not sleeping well. Two different people are operating. the morning and in the evening in my brain. Major contradiction, but my sister taught me this trick, and she calls it 10 minutes to save the world, where she puts on a 10 minute timer, and she has 10 minutes to clean as much as possible before the timer goes off, or she will do it for five minutes and just see if she can get all the dishes done, and it's like this race.
突然之间，也许是你一天中最糟糕的部分，有了一种全新的快乐光芒。这不仅有趣，也是一种动力。甚至还有一款专门为此开发的应用程序。我想它叫做“习惯RPG”（Habit RPG），它基本上允许你选择想要培养的习惯和想要戒除的习惯，并将它们以超级游戏化、愉快的方式与现实生活中的奖励挂钩。你甚至可以组建团队。
And suddenly, perhaps what is probably the worst part of your day, has this new kind of fun glimmer to it. And it's not just fun, it's also motivation. There was even an app developed to help people with this. I think it's called Habit RPG and it essentially lets you choose habits you want to promote and habits you want to kick and it ties them to real life rewards in like a super gamified, enjoyable way. And you can even create teams.
所以它简直就像是一个电子游戏，它把我们通常会讨厌、可能会从生活中榨取快乐的事情变成了一场游戏。用更简单的方式，你也可以把趣味带入你生活的任何领域，而不仅仅是那些烦人或令人沮丧的事情。你可以试着在早上赶火车的路上不踩到铁轨上的缝隙。你可以看看你能数出多少次看到有人穿同样的鞋子，和你的朋友们对午餐时坐在你旁边的人会点什么进行想象中的打赌。我认为这只是去拥抱这种开放的心态，就像——只是接受生活本身是多么滑稽，我们做的很多事情其实并没有那么严肃，但我们在心里把它们搞得那么严肃。
So it is literally like a video game and it's turning things that we would ordinarily hate and that might suck joy out of your life into a game. in a more simple way, you can also invite play into any area of your life, not just something that is annoying or frustrating. You can try not to step on the tracks on your way to the train in the morning. You can see how many times you can spot someone wearing the same shoes, place imaginary bets on what the people next to you at lunch are going to order with your friends. I think it's just inviting this open, like just being open to how like silly life kind of is and how so many things that we do are actually like not that serious, but we make them so in our mind.
这含蓄地联系到了我们的第四个技巧。像你童年时那样去做事。走路时用跳的。谁会在乎别人怎么看你？把麦片当晚饭吃。把冰淇淋当早饭吃。像看动画片一样看电视。故意让自己变得不那么一本正经。治愈你的内在小孩，我想这在几年前确实风靡一时。但它的价值并没有消失。你知道，曾经存在过的每一个版本。
This implicitly links to our fourth tip. Do things the way your childhood self would. Skip instead of walking. Who cares if someone judges you? Eat cereal for dinner. Have ice cream for breakfast. Like watch cartoons. Let yourself be unsurious on purpose. Healing your inner child, I think it really had a moment a few years ago. But the value of it hasn't disappeared. You know, every version of it. of you who has ever exists still exists within you. They are holding on to memories. They are representing the lessons you learned and who you were at certain stages in your life. That version of you with the childlike wonder is still there. We contain all these parts, all these roles, everyone we have ever been. And healing, any part of you often comes from listening to
的你，至今仍然存在于你体内。他们保留着记忆。他们代表着你学到的教训以及你在生命中某个特定阶段所是的那个你。那个充满童真惊奇的你依然在那里。我们包含了所有这些部分，所有的角色，我们曾经成为过的每一个人。而治愈你内心的任何一部分，往往来自于倾听、承认和尊重这些部分，尤其是那些可能被迫过早成熟的年轻的内在部分。而且，你知道的，我之前说过医生不会给你开具快乐的处方。但如果心理学家或治疗师认为你童年时期的某一部分仍然受到创伤或伤害，他们有时真的会这么做。你会发现，一旦你开始倾听那个曾经傻乎乎、充满玩心、天真无邪的自己，你就很容易回到那种心态，不是因为你在退化，而是在反抗那些暗示你这种傻气和快乐已不再属于你的无意识潜伏力量。那不属于你。你年纪太大了，不适合那样了。我在这里郑重地说：不，你一点也不老。傻气、趣味
acknowledging and honoring those parts, especially the younger ones who may have had to grow up too quickly. And, you know, I talked about how doctors won't prescribe you fun. Sometimes a psychologist or a therapist just might, if there is a part of you from childhood who they believe is still wounded or injured. You will find, once you start listening to this version of you, who was silly and playful and innocent, it's very easy to slip back into that mindset, not because you're regressing, but because you are rebelling against implicit unconscious forces that have told you that this kind of silliness and fun isn't available to you anymore. It's not for you. You're too old for that. And I'm really here to say, no, you are not. Silliness and playfulness
和快乐并不仅仅属于童年。那么，你可以做些什么来让你的日常生活更有趣呢？那就是像你五岁、甚至十岁的自己那样去对待它。什么事情会让他们着迷？你小时候一直吵着要或渴望得到、而现在你有了成年人的金钱就可以自己满足的东西是什么？说真的，当你开始这样思考时，
and fun are not just reserved for childhood. So what can you do to make your daily life more fun by treating it the way your five-year-old self, maybe even your 10-year-old self would have. What things would they be fascinated by? What are the things you always asked for as a kid or wanted that now you have adult money, you can kind of provide? Genuinely, when you start thinking this way,
就像世界是你的牡蛎一样，你知道当你想象自己五岁的自己和你一起上火车时，坐火车会有多么有趣吗？你会看到并欣赏到那么多你的成年思维所看不到的东西。有那么多关于这个世界的事情让你感到惊奇。一旦你刻意地说：“嘿，也许我视为理所当然的那些随机琐事，实际上真的很……”
like the world is your oyster, do you know how much fun it is to get on a train if you're imagining your five-year-old self getting on the train with you? There's just so much that you see and that you appreciate that your adult mind doesn't. There's so many things that surprise you about the world. Once you deliberately say, hey, maybe the random stuff I take for granted is actually really,
就像世界任你驰骋一样，如果你想象着自己五岁时的样子和你一起上火车，你会发现坐火车有多好玩？你会看到并欣赏到许多成年人思维所看不到的东西。这个世界上有那么多事情让你感到惊奇。一旦你刻意去想，嘿，也许我理所当然看待的那些随机事物实际上真的非常
really special. And initially it is going to feel strange. You know, that's the social conditioning kicking in. The social conditioning that's saying you're an adult now, behave like one. And then acting like a child sometimes is going to feel really, really liberating. And you know what? Who cares if you feel. weird or cringe. I think feeling cringe is better than feeling joyless and better than feeling cold
真的很特别。起初你会觉得这很奇怪。你知道，那是社会禁锢在起作用。社会禁锢告诉你，你现在是个成年人了，要有个成年人的样子。有时候像个孩子一样行事，会让人觉得非常非常解放。你知道吗？谁会在乎你觉得诡异或尴尬呢。我觉得感到尴尬总比失去快乐好，总比感觉冷冰冰的好，
and better than never trying anything new. And I always say this if you're a long time listener of the show, people who are weird and who are fun and who throw caution to the wind, they're the most interesting people out there. I want to now quickly give some air time to the tips that you all, the wonderful listeners, sent in about how you are making life more fun for yourself in the most niche and interesting ways. So I went on Instagram and I was like, I'm going to crowdsource some joyful, delightful activities. And a lot of them were somewhat similar. It was like romanticized, dance, sing. And then some of you were just so creative. And I will say there's a couple of these that I have done. And I had so much fun doing it. It made me feel so like peaceful when I went to
总比从未尝试任何新事物要好。我总是这么说，如果你是节目的老听众，那些古怪有趣、把谨慎抛诸脑后的人，才是世界上最有趣的人。现在我想快速腾出一点时间，分享一下各位优秀的听众发来的建议，关于你们是如何以最冷门、最有趣的方式为生活增添乐趣的。我当时上了Instagram，说我想征集一些快乐、愉悦的活动。其中很多都大同小异，比如浪漫化生活、跳舞、唱歌。但你们有些人真的太有创意了。我得说，这里面有好几个我都做过。我做的时候觉得太开心了。当我准备睡觉时，心里感到无比平静。
sleep at night. Okay, here's the list. Buying small bundles of flowers to make my own bouquets for family and friends. I read my book at a coffee shop for an hour and I call it book camping. I love that. Nurf war with my roommates? Yes, please. I chase my partner around the house and we play tag. I actually do that one. This one was so funny and I've been thinking about it all day. Go to karaoke and use the microphone to gossip, which like, yes, that's hilarious. This person said, have bubbles or party poppers in a small jar in my house for small accomplishments. Me and my friend schedule meetings with each other throughout company emails, even though we work in a completely different place and we jump on business calls with each
好了，清单如下：买一小束花，为家人和朋友制作我自己的花束。我在咖啡馆读一个小时的书，我管这叫“图书露营”。我太喜欢这个了。和室友打Nerf软弹枪大战？好啊，求之不得。我追着伴侣满屋子跑，我们玩捉迷藏。其实我也做过这个。这个太搞笑了，我一整天都在想这件事：去唱卡拉OK，然后用麦克风八卦，这简直太搞笑了。这个人说：在家里的小罐子里准备一些泡泡或者礼炮，用来庆祝小小的成就。我和朋友通过公司邮件互相安排会议，尽管我们在完全不同的地方，而且我们每周都会开一次商务视频会议。
other once a week. When I go running, I try to smile at everyone who I run past. This person just said trinkets. Another person said dance party at least once a day. This one I thought was really, really sweet. I keep stickers in my cash register to give the kids at work. How joyful is that? I want you to notice something about all these suggestions. None of them cost more than $20. In fact, most of them are free. That's the brilliant thing about Fun that we mentioned before. Fund is probably one of the most affordable medicines. It's one of the most affordable wellness trends, most affordable health remedy you will probably ever encounter. And I think the things that we take for granted are sometimes the things that come to us
当我跑步时，我试着对每一个从我身边跑过的人微笑。这个人只说了一个词：小饰品。另一个人说每天至少开一次舞会。我觉得这个真的非常非常贴心：我在收银机里准备了一些贴纸，送给工作时遇到的孩子们。这有多快乐啊？我想让你们注意到这些建议的一个共同点：它们的成本都不超过20美元。事实上，大部分都是免费的。这就是我们之前提到过的“乐趣”的奇妙之处。“乐趣”可能是最实惠的良药。它是你所能遇到的最实惠的健康潮流、最实惠的健康疗法之一。而且我认为，那些我们视为理所当然的事情，有时正是最轻易就能得到的事情，
most easily, like breathing, like spending time in nature, like connecting with someone, like having fun. So I hope that this episode has persuaded you in some small way to make this a daily practice. If you do any of these things, take a photo, tag me in it. I want to see it. Message me if you do anything from that list and tell me how it goes, especially if you do the karaoke one, because I don't know, I'm just so fascinated by that. Whoever sent that in, like you have changed, you've changed my mind about so many things. I feel like I need to go and do that, like treat it like a podcast almost.
比如呼吸，比如在大自然中度过时光，比如与人建立联系，比如获得乐趣。所以我希望这一集能以某种微小的方式说服你，把这变成日常习惯。如果你做了其中任何事情，拍张照片，标记我。我想看。如果你照着这份清单做了什么，请给我发消息告诉我结果如何，特别是如果你去了卡拉OK，因为我不知道，我对此太着迷了。无论谁发来的这个建议，你改变了我对很多事情的看法。我觉得我需要去尝试一下，就像把它当成播客一样。
But this is something I want to be honest. I'm still working on myself. And I know there are a lot of excuses to not feel joyful. and I know there are a lot of excuses that I personally am making myself to not just take a freaking afternoon off, to not just say yes to things that are silly. And I have never once regretted having fun, but I have a lot of times regretted saying no to opportunities for fun. Just the simple math of that I think is persuasive enough for me.
但有一点我想诚实地说：我自己还在努力。我知道有各种借口让自己不去感受快乐，我也知道我自己一直在找各种借口，不肯单纯地给自己放个下午假，不肯对那些傻乎乎的事情说一声“好啊”。我从来没有因为获得快乐而后悔过，但我有很多次后悔拒绝了寻找乐趣的机会。单单是这种简单的算账，我想就已经足够说服我了。
From a very utilitarian perspective, fun is. regret proof. So I hope you enjoyed this episode. Make sure that you are either subscribed on YouTube or you are subscribed on Spotify, Apple, turn on notifications so you know when new episodes come out. And you can also share this episode with a friend, someone who you think might get a real kick out of it. Someone you think may or may not need some more fun in their life. I really enjoyed speaking about this. It's probably one of my favorite episodes I've ever made. So if you've made it this far, leave a little emoji that represents fun for you in the comments.
从极度功利的角度来看，乐趣是绝对不会后悔的。希望你喜欢这一集。请确保你在YouTube或Spotify、Apple上订阅了我们，并开启通知，这样你就知道新节目什么时候发布。你也可以把这一集分享给一个朋友，你觉得他会从这个节目中获得乐趣的人，或者你认为生活中需要更多乐趣的人。我非常喜欢聊这个。这可能是我做过的最喜欢的节目之一。所以，如果你听到了这里，请在评论区留下一个代表你心中乐趣的小表情。
And until next time, stay safe, be kind, have more fun, be gentle with yourself. And we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships. And you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
直到下次，保重，保持善良，享受更多乐趣，对温柔以待自己。我们很快就会再聊。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。欢迎收听我的播客2%。我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理坚韧、健身和培养抗挫力的科学。让自己经历一些苦难。你会以一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的姿态从另一头走出来。收听2%。
That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a hear, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors.
在IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方搜索“TWO%”。在《回顾过去》播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和亚历克斯·英格利夫来说是个大时刻。每一期节目，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。
Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.
就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代一样。84年真是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。嘿，大家好，你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·加姆斯主持的《艰难成长》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都不太安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士在交流。
How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones.
多少人身披铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。但这并不意味着你有这个能力，就必须要这么做。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcast或任何你获取播客的地方收听《艰难成长》。2023年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。奥恩斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吧？我伪造了一次测试。
It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Rancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。还有另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·兰奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《受困之爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着季度的推进，劳拉·奥恩斯终于面临了后果。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《受困之爱》播客。这是一个IHeart播客。保证真人。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。